[ __ ] is he gone or what
no no no no
check this out
bro all right to think we're good where
the [ __ ] did it go though
again I sneeze
brah
now you laughing that
all right
did it a muscle salt
all right we're good I think we can get
out of the sewer now thank you very much
unless Asami wants a pair once more
that'd be [ __ ] great
why the [ __ ] not okay I think we're good
and oh we're not done oh no what what
what's going on here
no no no no take them what the [ __ ] no
no no are you kidding me
turn around
why why are you so disgusting White
Airways your job bro seriously
who kill that guy
who killed him
you see death
ah no no no no no no what do momento say
I buried gate was torn down by that
creature ah he's not dead
[ __ ] that oh thanks
I got an arm
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry to hide you see me
go away
oh my god
ah [ __ ]
oh my god there was nowhere to hide
[Music]
is it gone
bro
hello
I hate that guy
all right I would really want to make a
run for it
oh great he's still out there
where is a good question though
I guess there cuz that's where I'm going
what is it doing there
my god
what beared gate are you kidding me oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
don't tell me have to run past him
that's ridiculous I'm not doing that
is he just gonna stand there
oh god I hearing so much
I want to make a run for it I mean I've
quite fast can it be
there's got to be some way to distract
them
it's got to be some way
creepy room
let's try this maybe doesn't like arms
for what I know is I mean it's this has
got to be his friends on
bro I have a present for you
oh [ __ ] that's hope that worked
yet
run run run run for [ __ ] sake oh [ __ ]
why is he climbing so slow look down
seriously
Oh God I'm taking him all right welcome
back to whatever part I lost count a
long time ago we came from that well
climbing that ladder and was not
pleasant here she really was horrible
I'm glad we're down with done with it
super and but let's see this this looks
just as creepy to be honest so looks
like we're in some kind of towers
yeah this looks really really bad I got
a feeling the monsters gonna show up
here as well that makes me sad face
tell I'm not supposed to do with this
budge won't budge
I don't even know that means
oh it's puzzle yay August 1839
I can't stop sweating why was that
Daniel it sounds weird the warding
ritual was not something of a sane mind
I did not even realize the dungeon was
still in use Alexander had his servants
bring one of the prisoners a murderer he
told me Alexander made all the
arrangements but he said I had to
perform the ritual in order to have the
right effect the shadow could be led
astray by the blood of another killing
the man would provide us precious time
what else could I do
Alexander said it had to be done he is
saving my life I don't have the luxury
of argument Oh poor Daniel
he's rude
I'm really curious about this ritual
whatever oil again I will already got
oil now it's not working
something must be wrong with the
machinery yeah why not everything is
working so well in this goddamn castle
god damn it
budge
dead-end
all right creepy corridor why not
oooh this looks scary I don't wanna go
down there not at all Wow creepy